I have here the number 324 which we can
view as since I have a 3 in the hundreds
place we could say this is three
hundreds I have a two in the tens place
so we could say plus two tens and then I
have a for the ones place so I can say
plus four ones and if you want to think
about what that looks like you can look
at all these blocks here three groups of
100 three groups of hundred one two
three two groups of ten two groups of
ten I have two groups of ten right over
here in yellow for ones I have four ones
here so this is 324 blocks so now let's
get some practice subtracting from 324
and the first thing I want to subtract
from 324 is let's subtract let's
subtract a 10 so I want to subtract a 10
here so 10 is 1 10 and 0 on 0 1 so I'm
going to do that in the blue color 0
ones so I'm not subtracting any hundreds
I am subtracting 1 10 you see it right
over there so minus 1 10 and I'm not
subtracting any ones so what is that
going to get me what is that going to
get me
well my hundreds don't change I'm not
subtracting any 100 so I still have
three hundreds so I could write that
over here
I still have three hundreds I had two
tens I'm taking one of them away so now
I have 2 minus 1 is 2 minus 1 is 1 10 I
had two tens
now I take away one 10 I should just
call that a 10 instead of a tens I take
away one 10 and now I'm going to have
and now I'm going to have plus 1/10 if I
had to I take away one I'm not going to
have one and I had four ones and I'm not
taking anyone's away so I still have 4 I
still have 4 ones for ones - zero ones
four ones
so I'm left with 314 300 plus 1/10
four ones and if you look at it over
here what did we do we had 324 and then
we take away one of the tens so we took
away one of the tens and we are left
with three hundred 110 and four ones or
three hundred and fourteen that was
interesting that let's subtract 100 from
324 instead of a 10 so let's now
subtract let's now subtract a hundred so
that's 100 so I'm not going to subtract
100 and zero tens and zero ones so let's
subtract that now what's that going to
be well I had three hundreds I take one
of them away now I'm going to have two
hundreds I had two tens I take away no
tens I still have two tens I had four
ones I take away zero ones I'm still
going to have four ones if you look at
it over here what's that going to be let
me write an equal sign
I had three hundreds I take away one
hundred I'm going to have two hundreds I
had two tens I'm not taking away any
tens so I still have two tens and I had
four ones and I'm not taking away any
one so I still have four ones and if you
think about it in this picture here what
did I just do well I took away one group
of 100 I took away one group of 100 so I
could take away that group of 100 right
over there and what am I left with
I'm left with two hundreds two hundreds
two tens that's the two tens there and
four ones to hundreds actually let me
write to hundreds let me write it this
way to hundreds two tens for one or two
hundred and twenty-four